We're going to talk a little bit more
about streaming and in particular, specific applications
and how they work. We'll talk about
a streaming video application, YouTube, and a Voice
over IP or streaming audio application, Skype.
With YouTube, all uploaded videos are converted
to Flash or html5 and nearly every
browser has a Flash plugin. Thus, every browser
can essentially play these videos. HTTP and
TCP are implemented in every browser and the
streams easily get through most firewalls. So,
in this case, even though we've talked about
why TCP is suboptimal for streaming, the
designers of YouTube decided to keep things simple,
potentially at the expense of video quality.
When a client makes an HTTP request to
youtube.com, it is redirected to a
content distribution network server located in
a content distribution network, such as
Limelight or perhaps even YouTube's own content
distribution network. We will talk about content distribution networks later on
in this course. When the client sends an HTTP get message to this CDN server,
the server responds with a video stream. Similarly with Skype, or Voice Over IP,
your analog signal is digitized through an A to D conversion and
this resulting digitized bit stream is sent over the internet.
In the case of Skype, this A to D conversion happens by way of the application.
And in the case of Voice over IP this
conversion might be performed with some kind of phone
adapter that you actually plug your phone into. An
example of that might be Vonage. In VoIP with an
analogue phone the adapter converts between the analogue and
digitial signal. It sends and recieves data packets and then
communicates with the phone in a standard way. Skype,
on the other hand, is based on what's known as
peer-to-peer technology. Where individual users, using
Skype, actually route voice traffic through one
another. We will talk more about
peer-to-peer content distribution, later in this course.